[Music]
daddy
what's going on sweetie
something feels weird
something's changing you remember the
tools we type right
pencil desk paper shoes you're weird
everything okay charlie
it happened again what happened the bad
thing if you ever start to lose control
what do you do it didn't work
she's not a robot and she's a little
girl
with little girls emotions which are
wildly unpredictable
charlie she just has to shove it down
and keep it hidden
our responsibility is getting her ready
our responsibility is to protect her
charlie
if they catch her they're gonna put her
in a cage charlie
they're gonna run tests on her for the
rest of her life
i'll never see her again
if who catches me
something's happened i need it handled
with discretion
and i need her back alive holy [ __ ]
do you know what it means to be on the
run batman are after us really bad i
hate living like this
you're special charlie i'm not special
i'm a monster
i want to help her you want to use her
charlie don't be stupid please
do you feel that
let her go it's going to get a lot worse
she's the first of her kind
a real life
superhero
you need to understand how to use it
it can't be a reaction it's got to be a
decision
that's the only way that you control it
she's becoming a young woman i'm not
going to jail and someday soon
you gotta change the world
she may be capable of a nuclear
explosion
on your knees simply with the force of
her mind
trust me charlie
you don't have to be afraid
please i can help you liar liar
pants on fire
i don't want to hurt anyone
but it feels kind of good
my
[Music]
you